what up space fam goes in here from
anime up pro in today I'm going to be
talking about one of my favorite
characters in one piece shanks I've done
plenty how strong is videos for the
seven deadly sins and Demon Slayer and
so me in the comments suggested that I
do the same for one piece characters and
so here I am if you want to see more how
strong is videos for one piece make sure
to smash that like button and share this
video with a friend I'll get started on
the next one as soon as we get 4000
likes on this one also let me know in
the comments what character you would
like to see next
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
Bell or you will miss future one piece
videos the way I do these videos is that
I go over all the relevant information
that the manga reveals about the
character in question and use it in
order to determine how strong the
character is so most of the time there
will be manga spoilers now without
further ado let's jump into it red
haired shanks was introduced in the
first chapter of the series in fact
Luffy gets his iconic straw hat from
shanks in the first place
shanks was 27 years old at the time
while Luffy was 7 shanks his pirate flag
is the first one we see his true power
is initially downplayed in the chapter
shanks just seems like a nice guy who
gets angry with Luffy after the latter
cuts his face in order to show his
courage Luffy wants to join the pirates
but captain shanks discourages him
telling him he's too young then the
mountain bandit shows up he insults
shanks and spills alcohol all over him
after shanks was nice enough to offer
him the last bottle those shanks kick
his butt no he tries to clean up the
bandits call shanks and his men cowards
and leave shanks his men laugh and so
the shanks however Luffy is upset
in his view shanks got embarrassed and
came off as a weakling he should have
fought back instead of taking it and
laughs shanks then tells him and I quote
when you grow up maybe you'll understand
kid he just got some grog on me that's
all needless killing doesn't make you a
man and quote at this point shanks seems
to imply that he could have killed the
bandits but we still haven't seen him or
his crew in action when the bandits go
after Luffy that's when we see a glimpse
of what shanks is capable of the bandit
puts a gun at shanks his head a normal
person would be pretty afraid of this
situation but shanks is calm cool
collected and smiling shanks just tells
the bandit
pointing that gun at him means the
bandit is putting his own life on the
line then shanks his man shoots the
bandit in the head things just got real
now we're beginning to figure out that
shanks is not someone you should mess
with one bandit is ridiculous enough to
say that that Shaw wasn't fair but
shanks replies that they're pirates and
they don't play by the rules shanks says
you can pour drinks on me you can throw
food at me
you can even spit on me I'll just slap
that stuff off but good reason or not
nobody hurts a friend of mine and quote
then Ben Beckman shanks his first mate
takes care of most of the bandits he
even puts out a cigarette in one dudes
eye which is pretty epic the leader of
the mountain bandits pretty much wets
himself after seeing this throws a smoke
bomb and escapes with Luffy he throws
Luffy overboard and since Luffy ate a
devil fruit this means certain that for
him to make matters worse a Sea King
shows up it eats the Bandit and then
goes after Luffy just as Luffy is about
to be eaten shank shows up and pulls him
out of the way shanks loses his arm in
the process but he doesn't even flinch
he tells us seeking to get out of there
and the seeking leaves scared out of its
mind although we didn't know it yet this
was the first instance of conquerors
haki we see in the series
you'd think shanks could have used this
haki sooner but who knows maybe it was a
matter of time maybe he wanted to show
Luffy how dangerous the pirate life was
or maybe as some of you joked in the
comments shanks is so strong he
purposely nerfed himself by giving up
his arm whatever the case may be he lost
an arm and he was completely unfazed he
even comfort into crying Luffy and
considered his arm to be a small price
to pay this mental strength is one of
the reasons I respect shanks so much
he smiles calmly after losing his arm
and never holds it against Luffy not
even for a second he even gives Luffy
his prized straw hat furthermore he's
strong enough to scare off a sea king
his one man is strong enough to defeat
all the mountain bandits and yet he just
laughed it off when a weak mountain
bandit insulted him shanks is
practically egoless he doesn't care what
people think he knows that he is only
insulted if he chooses to be insulted it
is only when the chips are down and one
of his friends are in trouble that he'll
resort to violence however keep in mind
we didn't really see violence from
shanks himself lucky shot a dude been
wiped out a bunch and shanks scared off
a cking without raising a finger all
shanks did was lose an arm
and yet he's clearly strong he is
unfazed by losing an arm there must be a
reason he is a captain of such strong
fighters like Ben who can take out a big
group of experienced fighters without
breaking a sweat his men respect shanks
and follow him without him needing to
lift a finger they never think to
question whether a dude who lost his arm
is still strong enough to be their
captain shanks has complete loyalty and
his power seems all the greater because
he never needs to demonstrate it that's
a technique that oda will continue to
use in order to construct mystery and
hype around shanks we later find out
that when he was about nine years old
shanks apprenticed along with buggy
under gol D Roger the king of pirates
thus even at this early of an age he was
being exposed to some of the strongest
parts of all time including Roger and
white beard now at age 39 shanks is a
young ko meaning he is one of the Four
Emperors of the sea the yonk OU are
believed to be the four most powerful
pirate captains in the world along with
the world government and previously the
seven warlords of the sea they
maintained a power balance of the world
not only was shanks as an emperor
considered to be an equal of white beard
called the strongest man in the world
and Kaido called the strongest creature
in the world he also managed to achieve
this level without the help of a devil
fruit furthermore he's the youngest out
of all the yong-chol at 39 years old
meaning he potentially has a lot of time
to grow even stronger shanks his hockey
is off the charts we already mentioned
how he used haki to scare off the
seeking in chapter 1 but let's get into
more detail here he's one of the few
people who can use all three types of
haki including observation haki armament
haki and the rarest of all conquerors
haki shanks is haki is next level Luffy
used conquers haki alone to take out
50,000 opponents out of 100,000 during
the Fishman Island arc Alda has said
that shanks could have knocked out all
100,000 perhaps one of the best examples
of shanks is haki is when he went to
meet white beard on his ship many of
white beards men members of one of the
strongest pirate crews in the world pass
out due to shanks is haki
their ship is even damaged by his
overwhelming haki the craziest thing is
this isn't even shanks trying shanks
just says he has trouble staying relaxed
on an enemy ship
so he's accidentally causing this damage
imagine if you wanted to go all-out it's
insane to think about even white beard
can't help but mention shanks is haki
when the two clash even though it's not
a serious fight that haven't split open
showing how strong they both are this
wasn't white beard in his prime but it's
still impressive that shanks with one
hand and a sword can hold off white
beards immense strength and powerful
weapon before they clash white beard
mentioned how impressive shanks is duel
with me Hawk was the two used to be
rivals which also goes to show how
skilled shanks is he could survive with
no serious injuries in duels against me
Hawk the strongest swordsman in the
world we also know that shanks topped a
paramount war which was set to be the
greatest battle of the great pirate Age
before he arrived he intercepted Kaito
and somehow prevented Kaito from
attacking white beard then he shows up
blocks a kind whose punch like it was
nothing and stops the war black beard
and his crew are present and they
haven't thought much after getting white
beards powerful devil fruit black we are
just recently boasted that he is
invincible that he's the greatest that
his eras beginning and even he's like oh
snap shanks is here I'm now ready to
fight him yet Sengoku acai new and the
rest of the Marines all give up too even
though most of them don't want to shanks
calls a shot and takes the bodies of
white beard and ace so they can get good
funerals these are some of the strongest
characters ever and they don't even want
to test their strength against shanks if
that doesn't speak to the power of him
and his crew I don't know what does the
dude can to an extent control keidel
black beard and even the world
government shanks is power and influence
is such that shanks can even get an
audience with the five elders the public
heads of the world government who are
collectively referred to as the greatest
power in the world clearly shanks his
feats are beyond impressive we still
haven't seen what he's truly capable of
but he's not untouchable accordingly now
let's look at some instances that give
us hints about the possible limits of
shanks his power
first off shanks is clearly not
confident enough in
power to not be worried about Blackbeard
shanks tells white beard that he's
fought countless battles and received
countless scars but the only ones that
continue to eight are the ones over his
left eye he makes it clear that he
didn't get those scars on an adventure
or even when he was fighting mihawk he
says that the one who gave him those
scars was Blackbeard shanks goes on to
say that it wasn't because he was
careless Blackbeard was good enough to
give him that scar well as far as we
know shanks didn't even leave any
lasting scars on Blackbeard then he
mentions how Blackbeard laid low and
waited for his chance he didn't even
rise up to become a squad leader or make
a name for himself he hid himself behind
a giant shadow of white beard it was
only once Blackbeard had enough power
that he made his move shanks fears that
a man like that won't ever be satisfied
and he'll keep aiming for the top shanks
warns white beard that he and ace should
not go after Blackbeard because he's so
dangerous he says that to a yong-chol
who was referred to as a strongest man
in the world and the man closest to one
piece interestingly enough shanks didn't
take care of Blackbeard either it's not
as if he was like oh I'll save ace by
killing Blackbeard no he made a special
trip telling white beard to stay away
from him rather than making a trip to
kill Blackbeard all this implies that
shanks thinks very highly of
Blackbeard's power and is not so sure
that he or white beard could be
Blackbeard just because they want to in
addition to hyping a black beard this
also shows that shanks is not
all-powerful and the last time they
fought it even seems like Blackbeard got
the better of shanks because of the
scars shanks continues to fear what
Blackbeard is capable of and seemingly
didn't feel confident enough to try
taking Blackbeard out himself to be fair
the same can be said for Blackbeard
since black bear decided it wasn't yet
time to fight shanks when he showed up
at marine fort however this may not be a
1vs1 fear but a feared that also factors
in the power of shanks his crew along
with the fact that so many powerful
Marines and white beard pirates were
still present keep in mind though
Blackbeard gave that scar to shanks
before he achieved the power he has now
which includes white beards devil fruit
the most powerful
misiek last fruit that is set to be able
to destroy the world
besides that let's look at a very
interesting conversation shanks had with
me hawk as I mentioned shanks used to be
a rival of me hawks and used to duel him
he survived the clashes without any
significant scars but since me hawk is
referred to as the world's strongest
swordsman and shanks is a swordsman that
does seem to imply that me Hawk had the
upper hand although what white beard
said about how he still remembers their
duel seems to imply that they were close
enough to put on a good show the most
interesting piece of evidence we have is
the conversation that me Hawk has with
shanks after shanks has lost his arm
after shanks asks if me Hawk wants a
challenge and me Hawk replies and I
quote I don't challenge one-armed
husband's and quote here he heavily
implies that shanks is no longer strong
enough for me Hawk to want to fight him
one-on-one interestingly enough to no
one tries to correct me Hawk neither
shanks nor his loyal crewmen his words
don't seem to be empty as we've seen
again Zorro me Hawk backs up his harsh
words and at that time me Hawk even
implied that if the gap is big enough he
can tell who's more skilled and powerful
without crossing swords all those shanks
is obviously much much stronger than
Zorro was it's still possible that me
Hawk knows he'd win against shanks
without crossing swords so why is shanks
so feared and why does he hold so much
sway if it's possible that Blackbeard
could beat him what I want and even
likely that me ha could beat him
one-on-one well I think the answer lies
in something me Hawk said during the
paramount war he said about Luffy and I
quote it's not his powers or techniques
he possesses some quality that makes
people want to help him and in these
waters that is the most formidable power
of all and quote I think shanks is so
strong because he possesses this quality
too
we mentioned his insane hockey and he's
clearly an exceptional fighter but my
theory is that it is shanks his
influence and his powerful and loyal
crew that make him one of the most
powerful and dangerous pirates in the
world the angka are not the strongest
pirates per se they're the strongest
pirate captains
they all have crews that are extremely
powerful I'd argue that one-on-one me
Hawk could beat shanks but me Hawk is a
lone wolf
he has no crew if we factor in shanks
his whole powerful crew then mihawk
probably wouldn't stand a chance
I believe that Blackbeard could also
pose a threat to shanks one-on-one but
since shanks his crew was there along
with the remaining white beer pirates
and the Marines I don't think even the
insanely confident Blackbeard felt like
he could ensure a victory so he left in
order to wait for a more favorable
chance anyways that is my view on how
strong I think shanks is after looking
at all the evidence there's totally
space for debate here hu to order left
that space on purpose I'm sure to keep
us wondering and engaged however I think
that all those shanks is super strong he
is not the strongest character in the
series and there are multiple characters
that could be on his level or stronger
one-on-one like Blackbeard a me hawk
shanks truly shines when you combine his
power with his powerful crew and his
ability to influence others he could
successfully intercept Kaido get a hyped
up Blackbeard to leave the battlefield
get Marco the Phoenix to obey Him get
sangoku to agree to his terms and get
the five elders to meet him as mihawk
suggests that it's this quality that is
the most formidable power of all and it
seems like shanks arguably possesses the
most of it so far his ability to
influence people and get them to help
him along with his impressive individual
strength is what truly makes him one of
the most dangerous and powerful
characters in the world of one piece and
that is it for today's video thank you
so much for watching if you want to see
more videos like this make sure to smash
that like button to let me know and I'll
get to the next one as soon as we hit
4,000 likes on this video a special
thank you goes to our patrons over on
patreon who help us survive YouTube
issues and who helped make videos like
this one possible first and foremost I
want to think are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans Steven
and Greta a Lola autumn the world
stealers the school bus
Theisen Kirino acquired respect and
pattaya and I can't forget our pro hero
to your patrons the one and only
Gilgamesh nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Odin Anatole kazansky alpha do angel
Cruz team Sparky 65 Rohan Kapoor cricket
XP $30 beat Ted no Ted Salter Joel
Stanton very Gucci Jessica Calif on Ally
Shaktar emperor otaku and JCCC waka
thank you all so much if you enjoy our
work you can support more by going over
to patreon compro and becoming a patron
today for as little as $1 if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these amazing people
right here and you'll even get access to
our private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course dank
memes so check out patreon.com/lenguin
if you prefer whichever way you choose
to support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see you space cowboys
[Music]